dad coos mum the Nutcracker what does
that mean dad calls mum the knock it
means that she's strong and she gets
what she wants
oh yeah I'm Phoebe and I'm Ruby and
today ryoga be interviewing Keira
Knightley what qualities should a modern
Disney Princess huh um I think she
should be strong and she should save the
world obviously and she should not drop
her card I mean honestly Phoebe come on
[Music]
is that meant to be a frog or a prince
because somebody's written is Orlando
blah any debt or frog a prince
I'm guessing that you're saying a frog
or a principle of that sorry well they
were very princely to me oh no what are
you gonna do to me think of a number
from zero to ten boy don't tell me okay
I took oh I'm not very good at math
right yes I lied
oh no don't do this yep subtract the
name you started with Oh what this is
horrible
wait a minute guys twelve minus five
twelve minus five everybody
I'm sorry it was have you had to kiss
any frogs in your career what about any
princes I mean you have to kiss a lot of
frogs yeah cool thank you for that I'll
remember that
I'll do that when I go home don't follow
me from Essex can you do in less
exception can I do an Essex accent well
most of my family's from ethnic well a
lot my dad's side the families from
Essex but then you know so there's sort
of a bit more like that you know I've
got a bit of a essex accent in it Thanks
just like that
[Music]